House Majority Leader Nancy Pelosi
delivered the longest speech in house
history day apparently showing on for
more than eight hours in an effort to
pressure Congress to give amnesty to
illegal immigrants so now we have the
first Republican president in modern
times the first president really
who is anti-immigrant to minister to the
needs of God's creation is an act of
worship to ignore those needs is to
dishonor the God who made us we're not
asking for something off the top also
wall it is something that is yeah maybe
it is off the wall maybe the wall is the
issue here before vote Booker soon after
I yield back
I had no intention of yielding back mr.
speaker there's newcomers with all of
that hope and aspiration they make
America more American well went on like
this for many hours as we said she said
a lot of things but one thing blows he
said was striking listen as she
describes how her grandson badly wishes
he were of a different race watch I'm
reminded of them my own grandson he had
a very close friend his name is Antonio
who's from Guatemala and he has
beautiful tan skin and beautiful brown
eyes and the rest and this was such a
proud day for me because when my
grandson blew out the candles on his
cake they said did you make a wish and
he said yes I made a wish he said well
what is your wish she said I wish I had
brown skin and brown eyes like Antonio
so beautiful so beautiful the beauty is
in the mix was it healthy to hate
yourself for the way that God made you
Nancy Pelosi thinks it is and her
delight says everything about the modern
Democratic Party certain races are good
others are bad so bad that it's
considered beautiful to hate your own
innate appearance and want it changed
and that Pelosi is saying is one of the
main reasons she supports mass
immigration so America will look
different and in her view better than it
does now now whatever you think of that
idea it is a genuinely radical sentiment
nobody has said anything like that
on the House floor for a long time they
used to but they don't anymore and for
good reason elevating one race over
another is the definition of bigotry
Pelosi may not be sharp enough to
understand the consequences of what she
just said she may not even know what
she's saying but if you want to live in
a country where everyone doesn't hate
everyone else for the color of their
skin you ought not to say things like
that Democrats should stop talking like
this in public in the White House
meanwhile chief of staff John Kelly's
being attacked for saying that hundreds
of thousands of eligible legal
immigrants likely didn't sign up for
daca in part because some of them may
have been too lazy watch there are six
hundred ninety thousand official daca
registrants and the president sent over
what amounts to be two and a half times
that number to 1.8 million the
difference between 690 1.8 million were
the people that some would say were too
afraid to sign up others would say were
too lazy to get off there but they
didn't sign up well the left is howling
of course in jumping up and down like
that een as they are but think about
what he said daca did exist for five
years was a special carve out for people
brought here illegally under the age of
18 and there are a lot of ways the
federal government was helping people
sign up for it there were programs and
translators and lawyers a lot of things
available to help immigrants apply and
yet more than a million people who are
eligible to apply to the program failed
to do so why is that exactly and what
does it tell us about them Roberto
Hernandez is an immigration activist he
joins this Tiger bro thanks are coming
up hey Tucker how you doing I'm doing
great so I think it's a I think it's a
really interesting question so the
majority of the people who were eligible
for this program which I think is
unconstitutional in the first place but
it existed they didn't sign up for the
program now maybe something to say they
were lazy I don't think that's the
explanation I think they just didn't
care they didn't care about our law they
didn't care about following the rules in
a country that's not theirs and so they
didn't and I think that's worse than
laziness honestly you know Tucker ideal
Smeal oh my god you know first of all I
can't believe John Kelly the chief of
staff
of the White House of this country using
that kind of language you know to me
it's like it reminds me of the bullies
in third grade and if you really look at
why did people not apply people are
afraid Tucker look at all the ice raids
that are going on in this country right
now people are living in right now right
you know as such again that we don't
give me the same color thing it's not
about that it's nothing to do with that
these are citizens of other countries
there's no checking on any of the race
they're not picking on any other race
you know how many other you are seeing
any of these people become citizens
because you're making it a racial
question when it's a question of
citizenship so these people are here
illegally Obama said look I'm gonna let
you stay under this program I'm gonna
help you sign up under the Obama
administration not Trump Obama five
years ago and most of them didn't sign
up and now Trump is saying I'm giving
you citizenship anyway which I totally
disagree with but whatever that's the
fact
but the point is they didn't sign up so
what were they afraid of the Obama
people are like we're helping you give
you a translator and you still won't do
it why because you don't care that's why
you don't care about being legal what's
the other explanation but let's look
okay you bring up Trump now that you
bring up Trump let's talk about this
under a violent leaders just because you
know what that and he created a crisis
for taka simple it wasn't a crisis until
he made it a crisis a distraction Church
a distraction for this country of its we
have so many issues and crises that we
have in this country that should not be
the topic of this subject of what
mistakes in this country get you to I
want you just answers one question under
Barack Obama who offered this program to
people here illegally he said look I'm
going to let you stay give you legal
status and I'm gonna help
you sign up for it there's nothing I
won't do to help you sign up for it and
most of them said not interested I'm
turning on the programs return out the
translators the safe spaces you're
giving me why don't tell me if they were
afraid he was asking them to sign up and
helping them and they didn't what's the
answer why didn't they do that under
Barack Obama honestly well well if that
was temporary and Barack Obama quite
candidly failed by not getting
immigration reform done the first year
you know I am I'm trying to try to ask
you a question
didn't Barack Obama promised that he was
gonna do immigration reform the first
year that he was in office just does the
president make the laws in this country
or does the Congress you know it's
Congress right there you go good Obama
has just sort of had Democratic control
House Nancy Pelosi was ahead of that he
also had the Senate that was Democratic
control so you're not sure my question
not it no you're not answer my question
it's a really energy question I think it
tells you a lot about this population
that we're about to give citizenship to
we'll be voting in our next election so
we're at some subsequent elections so I
I hope we can get to the bottom of that
because it who tells us a lot Roberto
thank you very much good to see it